Mars didn't always look like this it may
once have been covered in oceans
but what if we brought all the Martian
water back and transformed the red
planet into one that's half blue
what would Mars look like if it was 50
land and 50 water
where would we even find enough water to
fill Martian oceans
and why might we have no choice but to
Nuke the red planet
this is what if and here's what would
happen if Mars was half land and half
water
long ago Mars could have been covered by
a massive ocean and there may have been
Rivers streams and lakes spreading out
across the planet too
it might be that billions of years ago
Earth and Mars had similar climates
yeah except the Martian ocean covered
only 20 percent of the planet compared
to Earth's 71
and the surface temperature was a bit
cooler all of that thanks to an
atmosphere that didn't stick around long
enough
four billion years ago Mars lost its
protective magnetic field
and the solar winds started to carry all
of its atmosphere off into space
a few hundred million years later Mars
changed from a warm wet worlds to what
we know it as today
cold and dry
only 18 of its ocean remains trapped in
Frozen polar ice caps
so if you wanted to turn Mars into a
half land half ocean kind of planet
you'd need to add a whole lot of water
now before we make Mars a more welcoming
place to live we should look back at our
own Planet our Citizens need help now
more than ever you know with growing
income inequality low wages and crisis
after crisis Americans have been
struggling to make ends meet and the
government has one powerful tool that
could improve lives the U.S tax code you
know instead of using subsidized
programs they could put cash into the
hands of people who need it the most so
they can spend it in ways that work for
them with cash support low-income
families can have peace of mind knowing
that they've got more control over their
daily lives and now it's crucial because
the value of the federal minimum wage is
the lowest it's been in 66 years
it's time to take action and protect
those barely making it despite their
hard work
giving our citizens assistance when they
need it is the most effective way to
change the landscape of our country and
our planet right now
unlike Mars most of Earth is covered
with oceans
so what do you say we donate some of
that water to our red neighbor
well let me tell you that's a very very
bad idea
to make Martian oceans as deep as
Earth's you'd need to ship out about 20
percent of our ocean water
and this would suck for our marine life
yeah leave the Earth's oceans where they
belong besides there are a few other
places in the solar system where you
could find water like Saturn's moon
Enceladus and Jupiter's moon Europa they
might have twice as much water as Earth
but to transport some of that precious
H2O you'd need to move massive ice
blocks through space
that this would be difficult to pull off
to say the least you'd need rockets
capable of transporting huge amounts of
weight and you'd need money
yeah a lot of it because the price could
be as high as fifteen hundred dollars
per kilogram
and considering how much water you'd
require well the final price tag for
this operation would be well into the
trillions yeah expensive I know but
there might be another way of bringing
Martian water back and you'll love this
one because it involves nukes
yeah you heard me right you're about to
Nuke the red planet
and yes this would give it some water
how well all that energy would release
Frozen Martian carbon dioxide
this would cause temperatures to climb
and thaw out the poles it would be kind
of like causing controlled climate
change only you'd need to detonate
around 3 500 nuclear bombs every day
and this would mean shipping twice as
many bombs daily as the United States
currently has in its entire Arsenal
that's an enormous amount of radioactive
material to release
and it wouldn't exactly make Mars
habitable
plus you'd still need a lot more water
to cover half the planet in oceans
yeah okay it seems like nuking
everything in sight isn't the best idea
maybe you should take a little planetary
history lesson instead
about 4 billion years ago during the
late bombardment period a Non-Stop
barrage of asteroids collided with Mars
this created enough water to eventually
make an ocean 300 meters deep
so all you'd need to do is recreate this
event today
you'd have to redirect at least a
million comets and meteors so that
they'd end up on a collision course with
Mars
as the Comets crashed into Mars they'd
burn up and release water vapor rinse
and repeat until you get enough water to
cover half the red planet
but where would this water go
well looking at Mars's topography you'd
find that all this new water would
settle mostly above its equator
Mars would have new land masses that
would look like continents
there would even be mountains sticking
up on some parts of the planet Olympus
Mons the tallest volcano in the solar
system would now Tower High out of
Mars's new Northern ocean
but just because you were able to bring
enough water to cover half the planet
that wouldn't mean it would last
because of Mars's low atmospheric
pressure all this water would easily
boil away
well wait how would it boil away if
water's boiling point is 100 degrees
Celsius
aha well that's the boiling point on
Earth
on Mars the water would start to boil at
zero degrees Celsius
Ah that's frustrating especially after
all the work you put in bringing all
this water to Mars
you'd have to hope that this water vapor
would work as a greenhouse gas
if it could trap enough heat in the
Martian atmosphere and turn Mars into a
lush terraformed world maybe then you'd
be lucky enough to be the only Earthling
ever to go for a swim on another planet
what would your first 100 years on the
red planet be like
well that's a story
for another
what if